as the temperatures heat up many across
las vegas like to take a dip
in the backyard swimming pool but a lot
of them aren't even
close to being ready yet orco mana
joining us live from a home it's near
buffalo and sahara
to explain why orco
brian many pools whether they're being
built or getting remodeled
look like this right now under
construction with a lot of work
left to do experts say it's because of
high demand during the pandemic
paired with production problems it's
getting hot for sure it'd be nice to
have it done
it's pool season in las vegas but taking
a dip in jarrod macarthur's backyard is
not possible yet he's in the process of
refurbishing his pool but some materials
are not available right now
it's going to be about a two week delay
the explanation he got the whole supply
chain in a lot of industries is
you know screwed up because of the
pandemic that's also impacting new pools
being built with the coronavirus forcing
people to stay at home
experts say the demand for backyard
swimming pools has skyrocketed
david mcfeeder's pool looks like this
because of delays
behind i see every other house seems
like building a pool right now so it's
expected and we are slammed local pool
contractors are keeping busy and say
there's another issue on the horizon a
chlorine shortage due in part to a
chemical plant fire in louisiana when
you have
that on top of the large demand of
people winning swimming pools
price has gone up maybe ninety dollars
for a bucket of tabs
to a hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty while it's unclear when things
will get back to normal macarthur is
doing what he can to stay ahead
including getting an extra bucket of
chlorine tablets
they had stock there but it was
definitely higher price than what it was
last time i bought it
now there are other systems you can have
in installed in your pool
instead of getting chlorine and that
includes salt water
and ultraviolet systems so that's
something to keep in mind as we see that
shortage take place
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now